uh while human beings are made in the
image of god it seems like
that is the terminology that they're
using instead of saying
born this way
yeah
um is that is that accurate in in in
your experience or is it
is it am i misunderstanding well i see
the bleed
find out on this episode of led live
[Music]
light exposing darkness
everyone welcome to led live and today
you can see we are not in our old set
this is a new set probably one that's
going to be temporary but today we're
excited because we have a guest wayne
blakely he's on the show with us so
welcome wayne thanks keith and we are
going to talk about some
you might say more sensitive issues at
least in today's culture there are
issues about gender identity
homosexuality and the different
doctrinal viewpoints that are in the
christian church today but before we get
there i want to for the viewers sake
they need to know a little bit about you
so why is it that we would be talking
about this topic you have a bit of a
past you might say when it comes to this
and a long history so could you go into
that a little bit
sure i was
raised christian i was adopted when i
was two and a half years old
uh by
by a very devoted christian family and
uh went to christian schools went to
uh christian you know church and
everything i guess
surprisingly because i i wasn't
expecting it i ended up with same-sex
attraction actually i was suffering from
gender dysphoria before they even were
labeling that okay and you know nobody
was talking about these things so it was
well it was really an evolution of of
what would eventually come to a point of
uh today you know in today's culture uh
broadcasting and
and promoting um lgbt ideologies but you
know nobody was doing that when i was
when i was growing up so it didn't
happen overnight
i know it kind of evolved and and
through
you know and i think everybody has a
different story some have similar
stories but i don't think there's a
singular cause
for homosexuality but we may discuss a
little bit about that a little bit later
in the program and and about what age
was that that you started having these
feelings desires questions i i you know
in in second grade i was already uh you
know playing doctor in the bathroom with
another boy in the restroom and so
there was something going on that i
didn't recognize what was what what what
it what it all was
um but as far as
experiencing
and knowing that the same track same sex
attraction element was there
was probably by the time i was in
seventh eighth grade and certainly by
the time i was in high school i knew it
was there is that a common age
i think there are a lot of people uh
that say you know there isn't they don't
know a day that they didn't have
same-sex attraction
and i would say for me that that as i
look you know the deeper and the further
back i go i see that that that was there
so and i felt like it was very awkward
because it was something that i didn't i
didn't ask for and here i am a christian
it sounds a little bit different because
you know if you observe little boys and
little girls they
you know when you're when you're a
little boy five six years old girls are
the most disgusting thing on the planet
you don't want to have anything to do
with them and so from one perspective
you could understand how
two little boys would be more buddy
buddy and and yeah i want to be careful
i phrased this but attracted to each
other not not necessarily sexually but
they would they would have a draw a bond
together and you could see
um
how
people might
might
either
use that as and say that that's when it
started or but
or it could be it could be different now
i'm guessing your experience was
different
it wasn't the like yeah where friends
and buddies and girls are gross it was a
little different than that a little
different experience
yeah i didn't i didn't see the girls as
gross i i be having been more effeminate
i i moved in the direction that i
identified more with the girls
okay what was kind of awkward to me were
were guys i didn't the the guy
bonds and friendships were not never
stuck they were not developing the way i
saw other guys you know like the sports
element
that would get guys out there you know
you know doing high fives with each
other and stuff and i was not sports
minded at all and i i didn't fit in
and so the they became the mystery
gender for me which i think contributed
largely to the wanting the affirmation
and the attention
and having been adopted
i basically had been abandoned by my
birth parents
and so i didn't have the connectivity i
was trying to make some kind of
connectivity and
honestly i believe that if we look at
things
from the perspective of the world and
the two forces within the world this
creates the great controversy
and the great controversy is who's going
to rule my life is it going to be christ
or is it going to be satan
we don't automatically think of you know
satan is so vivid in our minds that we
don't see ourselves as blatantly
committing ourselves to satan but
through little incremental decisions
along the way sometimes we'll end up in
his camp before we even realize it yeah
yeah he's a very subtle enemy sly that's
what the bible describes him as started
to paint a picture about how you were
and and what you grew up as and i'm
starting to see
maybe a
cultural component to this because i
think as you as you're growing up and
you're noticing
i'm not really like this and i identify
more with the girls
society has a tendency to reinforce that
for you and so it kind of pushes you
one direction now it's probably more
that way in yesteryear than it is now
right um now we see a lot of
affirmation
inclusion and things like that so
it's much more blatant it's much more
blatant yeah so how would you describe
the difference between
culture and christianity
that's a good question because i we've
really become culturally driven today
and the things that we adapt to today
can easily change tomorrow and by a
different narrative that somebody begins
and you get more people in agreement
with that narrative and then they start
running things but the one thing that
doesn't change
is is god's word so i often say to
people
you know without jesus you can do
whatever you want
but for a christian for somebody who's
id and today that's
what does it mean you know when somebody
says that they're a christian you don't
know to what level they're going with
that but i look at scripture as being
god providing us a blueprint a plan
for our lives and basically for the
history of this universe from genesis to
revelation he knows the beginning from
the end he knew what we were going to be
facing
as it relates to the lgbt plus issue or
marital issues between men and women and
so for a christian i believe that we can
go directly back to his word and know
what his desires and his plans and what
his counsel and his requests are of us
and he does it in an invitational way
and not a forceful way
so today we have a lot of people going
into the elements of human reasoning
rather and they're they steer clear of
scriptures a few people even open the
bible between you know one
uh worship day and the next it's it's
very
interesting
they see the bible as antiquated and
irrelevant
and what's taken over is human reasoning
not going back and reasoning with
scripture but just reasoning amongst
one's oneselfs and when they do open up
scripture
they just go well let's just reinterpret
it to to fall in line with what it is
that we want to do so you're really
getting to the heart of um
morality if you will and
um i took an ethics class in the last
couple years and presented with lots of
different ethical viewpoints it was
interesting one of the viewpoints that
we talked about is one that you're
describing now and that is relativism
you know and that is how we see a lot of
cultural things today it's it's relative
to whatever culture is and that whatever
the cultural norm is that's what we you
know that's the stream we swim with yes
and
the
very simple problem with that is what
happens when culture changes
and that can happen relatively quickly
yes so what was wrong
yesterday could be right today and then
tomorrow it could be something else but
with christianity there's there's what's
called objective morality and that is
there is a standard of morality that
transcends humanity so
if we
are
going by the bible by god's word or the
law of god whatever it's it's above us
which means
um it's a level playing field everybody
is to the same standard and it doesn't
change
so when it doesn't change everybody kind
of knows what to expect all the time
right and
a lot of people find that very
comforting yeah it's reliable it is a
bit
uncomfortable to be in the other camp
with relativism because you never know
which things are going to go and and you
know how people are
it
we don't always agree right and so
whatever the dominant thought is that's
able to enforce their viewpoint
what about the people who disagree
exactly so you have today
the allow you know it's like they say
the loudest voice you know gets the the
grease and
and i see that today happening with um
uh groups that are getting um political
attention
and how laws are being passed based on
emotions and feelings uh rather than on
facts yeah that's unfortunate
well
there are
i guess you might say
from your experience there's like four
different
uh viewpoints that we've used through
time
to
show where we're at when it comes to
when it comes to identity when it comes
to the bible when it comes to doctrine
and i'd like to go through those with
you a little bit
uh you have your cheat sheet over there
which is going to be more helpful i i'd
have to look back here at this screen
but i think the first one is revel yeah
you know keith this was interesting to
me because i left the lgbt community you
know and gave my life over to christ
12 years ago
and i was
you know i believed i i i had done the
right thing i i had given my life over
to christ and i don't identify as gay
any longer and i'm going down the road
here and i'm going
there's got to be something else you
know there's got to be something more
and one day i
am
looking at youtube and i
began to browse x-gay testimonies
and i ran into an interview that
introduced me to these four positions
okay actually these positions are um
been put together by jason thompson from
portland fellowship ministries which is
in portland just across the river from
where i live
and
i sat there and i was stunned as to how
right on they were and and so it it has
actually revolutionized you know my
ministry okay and so
yeah you mentioned the the first
uh of the positions is the revel
position and it was interesting i took
the slides originally and i took that v
and and turned i thought it was a
typographical mistake and so i turned it
into a change into a b because i thought
it was the rebel position
and you know then then i one of the
people that was influential
on this said to me well yeah you could
really say that because it kind of is
that that position
but really what it is is about a person
who's reveling in their sin
uh from a christian standpoint this is
would be that first column in the
position that how it affects the church
today
is the idea that um
that i was born this way
and you know that that actually is
running out even in the lgbt community
today because the argument is not
holding up well there's no scientific
background for it still and so it's
getting tiresome to hear that over and
over again so they're moving to a
different position
but still there are many feel like since
this is unchangeable uh is wait it's the
way god purposed them to be
yeah i i hear
i i still hear this
uh even in in recent
video clips you know for example i
watched
president joe biden he released a
um i guess he did an executive order and
he did a press statement and things like
that and one of the terms that he used
was made in the image of god
while human beings are made in the image
of god it seems like
that is the terminology that they're
using instead of saying
born this way
yeah
um is that is that accurate in in in
your experience or is it
is it am i misunderstanding well i see
the bleed and as we talk about these
four columns though there is some
bleeding in in in between the columns
from one side to the other um i have not
heard too much but i can see how it
would come about that if you know we are
made in the image of god and then they
then they try to say
why you know i was protested recently
and they had signs that said you know
god is gay and so it it is
it it is open
or it seems to be open to interpretation
of the person who's trying to make the
point and so there it wouldn't surprise
me that lgbt people are are
from from the militant standpoint are
trying to drive a point that again
god doesn't have any problem with this
that's how he intended us to be to begin
with okay
we're not quite there yet that with the
revel though this is um the reveling is
is in the idea that this is this is
static there's no need to change it's
it's god doesn't intend for it to change
i don't need to look at the root causes
because
i am who i am this is how i arrived and
it's how i'm going to live and that god
doesn't have any problem with
same-sex marriage or gay relationships
uh it's
it's it's just a knowledge just normal
yeah yeah yeah and then and therefore if
it's normal and um god doesn't have a
problem with it then nobody else should
either is really the
what they're driving at exactly so so
this
probably about eight or nine years ago
um there were there's a gentleman by the
name of matthew vines who began to take
there's a youtube present presentation
that he was doing um
to christians
and he's from the methodist church
they were old arguments but because it
was a fresh young new face that was
promoting this idea
that traditionally the bible has said
this traditionally that in fact he has
made it a point to say that if god is
against homosexuality well so he would
be against homosexuality as well
but his position is is that in the bible
what god was against was
incest and sexual abuse and promiscuity
but when you have consenting adults who
are same-sex
who have fallen in love with each other
that god has no problem with that
whatsoever
and so scripture is manipulated and the
incidences the historical incidents
incidences uh surrounding
scripture are manipulated to the point
that even conservative pastors were
starting to buy into this
reshaping of scripture and so many have
have switched sides on this
believing this new interpretation of
scripture
which
consequently has divided the methodist
church oh really that's that's
essentially what it was because i know
that they recently well within the last
few years went yeah so they officially
split in may of this year oh may of this
year wow that's that is pretty recent i
knew it was coming
um but i thought it had happened a
couple years ago but maybe that was that
was um they were having started
conferences like their general
conferences where the taka from both
sides and there was a bit of a tug award
that went on and then the meeting of the
minds came together about what could
they
uh consolidate in some way or was this
going to remain you know
diametrically opposed to one another and
so it yeah it has it has split and there
have been previous denominations that
have experienced this too presbyterians
lutherans
do they rename
or
not sure where they're at with that um i
i
i don't know what's going to become of
that i know they have to do something to
distinguish distinguish between them
yeah that makes sense well when i was
looking at this earlier um it did remind
me of something in the bible because you
know when you think of somebody reveling
you think of
they're very proud of their position
they're just kind of glory in their
position and the bible has some
some counsel in jeremiah 9 24 it says
this says but let him who glories glory
in this that he understands and knows me
that i am the lord exercising
lovingkindness judgment and
righteousness in the earth for in these
i delight says the lord amen god is a
very um
well-rounded you might say character
he's a perfect balance of
love and
justice or mercy and justice
and that's one of the things i really
appreciate about god is that he's
so
fair
you know when it comes to
everything
absolutely i think in this rebel column
it's it's important for somebody who may
be lgbt or that's watching or a parent
or a sympathizer
i when i came back to christ i had to go
back to the beginning of um
to figure out how all this happened
and when you looked back to heaven and
the fact that there was war in heaven
and that the
the archangel and the position that he
had is suddenly painting god as being
unfair and unjust
then he distributes his
his pride of his position
to a third of heaven
who also pridefully leaves or is cast
out and says no
we don't
want to
um you know we don't want to remain we
don't think that god's ways are fair and
just and so we want to actually
or lucifer wanted not to be equal to god
but to be higher than god
and then when they left heaven left
heaven they became they've lucifer said
to them that they were holy beings and
then they needed to follow the dictates
of their own will
and i see that's what's happening today
if you believe in a great controversy
between good and evil
the way that the enemy would grab our
attention would be to to
help us facilitate our bodies into what
we desire and what we wish and then to
become prideful about it and so it's no
surprise that we have gay pride parades
because we are proud of the position of
which we've adopted that doesn't
necessarily agree with scripture but
because there is a
a dark cloud that has hung over that
position
now uh gay christians are seeking to
come back to the core of christianity to
reshape as much as they can to get
people to get on board with them to
believe in these ways that aren't
directly in agreement with how the bible
reads right and so this revel position
becomes very
influential
by having this loud voice that's out
there today and promoting
you know the lgbt community what didn't
didn't evolve from a christian
perspective jesus wasn't at the center
of it it evolved from um the sexual
revolution which really began for gay
rights movement in a in a gay bar in new
york city uh called you know stonewall
so i i think it's important you know if
you're going to if you're a believer or
if you have an inkling towards
god and wanting to do his will
to recognize how we got a little bit off
track and what it is that that god you
know actually has to offer us today
there's a um
there's a well maybe i'll get to that in
a little bit um
looking at this rebel position i want to
i want to look at some of these points
here
there's an identity right there's a
belief
yeah an lgbt identity yeah that you are
you are compelled to be this way and
that is that is the only i guess with
this position it's the only acceptable
identity
would you would you say that's fair yeah
i would say it's a celebratory identity
that's okay we hear it and all the
letters that are getting added to it
every day okay that it's the belief is
that it's open and affirming
correct okay
so and then there is a theology and an
ethics that are very liberal
right so now there there's been what's
uh referred to as as queer theology
they're moving away from that term to
you to another term called queer theory
um which is basically the same thing
okay but why would they why would they
do that i'm not sure i think that the
theology thing got compromising for for
people and so uh to say the theory
instead of theology uh made it easier
for people to adapt to okay i could see
that yeah because when you get to
theology it tends to touch very deeply
into people's lives
um you alluded to this too that it's a
born this way position is the way that
god designed it
live and let live when it comes to
marriage and it's strongly opposed to
any kind of healing yeah
i mean
i guess i guess this position would say
there's there's no need of healing
correct so so that this would create a
strong adversity to
to a
you know it's really it's it's rather
duplicitous because there are those in
this column that would call themselves
gay christians but at the same time they
would be against uh
the idea of conversion therapy and which
is a whole nother
conversation but but in the elements of
of conversion therapy that would be
trying to help people adopt um the bible
for how it reads
you know it it's it's really hard to go
down that road and navigate that unless
you try to totally debunk uh that and
and make it according you know it's it's
like this position is like the new
bible you know like you need to believe
that this is only the position yeah yeah
yeah so
that's kind of interesting
um in my mind because
if you want to promote
the idea of being open and inclusive and
affirming and you know have a very broad
loving perspective
that would include other people's
perspectives right not just right it can
only be this way this is extremely
narrow
and this is what runs the risk of of if
you push only one narrative
you know that's it it starts sounding
more marxist you know because if you get
this all written into law that
everybody's a carbon copy of everybody
else
that's i don't think that's the way that
god intended for us to be you know in
this world
yeah i agree with that god is very um
he allows a lot of freedom
now
i guess you might say that god is you
know he lays everything out there and
then he gives you the choice it doesn't
mean that there aren't consequences for
your choice exactly but that's life i
mean i think if we didn't have a
christian perspective we would still
come to that conclusion because we see
it in simple things you know
um
there's a reason i don't stick my hand
in a fire right it hurts yeah there's a
consequence you know people naturally
understand
consequences so
that's what i appreciate about god is
he's like look
i'm going to tell you the right answer
but if you don't want to choose the
right answer
you don't have to yeah you're free to
choose whatever you want you just need
to know that if you choose that way
there are consequences so we saw the
results you know that's why the
beginning's so important we saw the
results of the garden of eden and the
and what happened as a matter of
disobedience and and god had made it
very clear of where to go and where not
to go and and and so when you color
outside the lines
there
there are these consequences and
now we've ended up with the stain of sin
on us so our natural propensity is
towards sin
yet still says god to us you know i've
given you life and that while i've still
given you life i've also given you the
power to decide
you choose i'm going to tell you what
what my kingdom is about and what
pleases honors and glorifies me but i'll
also give you examples of what the enemy
strives to do he's going to try to
capitalize on your senses on your
feelings your touch your smell
you know your um
your desires of your flesh
are going to probably scream and holler
at you
but
you have this choice you can follow that
path
or you can deny yourself for me
and if you deny yourself for me we'll
escape this world eventually um because
we're really here a brief time you know
as you look over the course of the
history of time 100 years isn't isn't
much if even if somebody makes it
through 100 years in their life
so he's given us lots of good
information to follow
um the campaigns that are being made
today
are certainly against christ not for him
because the world has to come to a point
where god intervenes and says all right
enough and i think that we're we're
getting into those crosshairs now and so
it's important for someone to really
open up their heart to jesus and say
what do you really desire and want from
me all right well i don't want to get in
the theological weeds here but there is
this idea that god is externally
imposing all these punishments and
really the way that the bible describes
what happens is they are natural
consequences so for example when it says
the wages of sin is death that's
actually a natural consequence
whenever sin exists death exists with it
it's not that god is saying well because
you sinned now you're going to die i
want to make sure that you're going to
die it's just that that's what sin
automatically leads to it leads to death
and destruction
so
i always like to clarify that because
people will get the wrong idea about the
character of god that he's just you know
sitting up there almost like a zeus type
figure hurdling lightning bolts at
people whenever they do stuff wrong
which is a great construct and not the
god of the bible no and that's a where
the that's a whole another worthy
conversation too is the character of god
and this great love and
and depth of love for us through
what we're experiencing which is it's
tough it's tough on that you know we if
this is not heaven so we we're here to
be servants of god and to uh uphold you
know his
his honor and that's not going to be
it's not going to be easy at all and so
to the call to deny one some oneself
is something that has to be taken very
seriously because why would you give up
um
how you feel
for someone you don't really know so
exactly intimate with god and getting to
know him are vital to our conversation
about these columns and so i i kind of
want to move to this uh next column
which is the resist column now the
resist is can be very closely connected
with the rebel column because the resist
column is one in in which a person
believes again that you know this is how
i am
although i agree that god has his ways
and it wasn't his plan for us
uh to be like this but it's the way it
is and
and so i've arrived um
uh
lgbt
and
it's fixed and it's unchangeable in fact
i believe that god's character is what's
important and i'll hold myself even
maybe celibate for christ i'll even live
for him in that way because i believe
his word is true
but
as it relates to me
personally there's there's there's this
is just how i am there's no change
that's going to happen and so
in this column people don't even
they don't they also don't go and look
at the roots
of the of the problem because they
believe that that is too much of an
overbearing burden on the person and
that's just going to cause them pain and
grief again on these lines of conversion
therapy that it would just it would mess
up their life so you moved from
change is not even desirable like why
would i want that at all yeah because
it's important to
changes
it's not abhorrent it's it's not evil
it's just not possible yeah yeah yeah
yeah slightly just it is a slight change
it it makes me think of what the bible
says in second corinthians 5 17 and and
i think this is important just in
christianity in general
every person who comes to christ every
single person
there's a change
yes
and and and i like the way the bible
says it says therefore if anyone is in
christ so you've come to christ and now
now christ is part of your life it says
he is a new creation
old things have passed away behold i
have
it says all things have become new
from from old to new that's a big change
yeah
and jesus is telling us if you've come
to me
i can do that
in this in this column and what you're
pointing out
with the change that happens actually
that's that's a
a
a promise of freedom
because when you're locked into a
narrative you know which which this is
and all the rules of that narrative
um that's very limiting but in christ
philippians 4 13 says all things are
possible
and it's not just um this particular
issue that's that's the thing that's
true i think exciting for a lot of
people you know
you know to help i guess relate to to
our audience and and people in general
not everybody is is
uh facing the lgbt
you know plus issue
some people they're just they're just
struggling with
lying
stealing
uh lustful thoughts uh towards a a
a woman or a you know if they're a woman
a lustful thoughts towards i mean people
of all walks of life
in in all kinds of different ways and
all kinds of different cultures struggle
with this idea of they do things
and at least from a christian context
they know that they're not
right
but christ says you don't have to be
that way anymore like
you know in the apostle paul that wrote
much of the new testament
he was one way
and then god changed his heart and he
became another way to where he wasn't
like that anymore he no longer
persecuted people for their different
beliefs he decided to
educate them instead you know there's
there's all kinds of examples of the way
people have changed if we go to second
corinthians 5 17 if you go on to 18 and
19 it talks about us not only becoming a
new creature in christ but to go on with
the ministry of reconciliation and
that's what paul did yeah you know he
cha he was changed from one man to to
another
uh um
promoting the the trustworthiness of
jesus and a relationship with god and um
and his new found freedom in christ and
so
you know he did that to the point that
he was willing to be uh persecuted and
to be put in prison
and
so i you know we find that today even in
ex-gay ministries today
i'm not in a popular position today i'm
beat up on the outside and on the inside
as well but it doesn't stop me from
wanting to still promote the the love
and truth message and they do go
together you can't separate the two they
need to go together um so that we you
know the truth yes it is
uh there is discipline involved in truth
sometimes
but but the love is what helps get
move us along the way to the goal that
christ has set before us
i guess what i really appreciate about
the idea of change is
if i want to change
and there's
no hope
then
what
in in and don't take this the wrong way
i'm just i'm just asking a question
what's the point of jesus
like why i mean it's it's like okay you
died for my sins and they're forgiven
and thank you
but i still have a problem
and if that problem is plaguing me day
in and day out and there's no hope for
any change in my life it's kind of like
yeah absolutely well okay you're gone
but you're not really that powerful
right so that brings up you know the
blood what the the the the payment of
christ for our sins and and that we can
go to him to get the healing to get the
forgiveness um to become the new person
in christ those are all methods
important aspects of our walk with god
yeah
this is interesting too in this in this
resist column um as as in the revel
column identifying as a gay christian
you don't see people walking around
identifying themselves as heterosexual
christians
so it's
so then i have to contemplate again why
do i need to put this label before
christ so if you take a gay let's define
that by saying that this is a person who
prefers to have intimate relations with
someone of the same gender
christian
who just got dethroned
and so it i the importance is all on
self
rather than on my
the the giver of life to me um and and
so i think i think that it's important
for us to
recognize kind of the ridiculousness of
of identifying as a gay christian or
putting a label before christ
if we were fully and totally surrendered
to christ we would only want to identify
by who he says that we are exactly which
is really what that text is getting at
in second corinthians it's like if you
are new
well who gave you that new identity
exactly it was it was jesus and so and
and
you know
you i mean ultimately if i've come to
god and he's forgiven me and he's
changed me i would want to be identified
as what he identifies me as not not how
i identify me and that's i guess
you know speaking more broadly this is
one of the
maybe gripes i have with aaa
is that absolutely you continue to
identify as an alcoholic where you could
be dry for 40 years right and to me
no it's not it's not how christ sees you
he's like no
you're not an alcoholic
you are
a creature a new creation
so
yeah bill uh wilson who who brought
about aaa basically put an albatross
around your neck
so you really have that hanging over you
and i've talked to many audiences
about this
in that when you give your life to
christ
and you become sober and you become that
new creation in christ you you have a
bright future whereas if you walk around
with this cloud over your head that this
is what's always going to tempt you and
you need to identify by your temptations
and your desires it
it kind of pulls you in the wrong
direction it's a magnet to that
i listened to a sermon once which i
fully agree with is our identity comes
from who we've given our heart to
and so i did at 18 years old i gave my
heart to the lgbt community because i
thought i found my newfound love
you know in christ where in essence um
if i would had my focus on who i am and
jesus christ i'll be drawn more towards
him instead of towards what where
culture was leading me yeah so that's
that's intrinsic of the of the resist
column and residing there
and i would say that the resist column
and the revel column are what pulls us
to to the far left whereas we move
forward
to the next column
which is where i where i was when i came
in touch with these four perspectives
okay i found that um that what was being
described to me was exactly who i was i
was like yeah yeah that's who i am you
know because they said this is a person
who has
given their life over to christ they no
longer identify as gay but they identify
as a new creation in christ so they've
dropped that old identity
and embraced the new identity in christ
and they surrender
their desires and their temptations
but many see that even their desires and
temptations are sinful
and
i agree with the fact that as james
tells us there are are points within
desire and temptation if we fondle it if
we keep it alive in our memories it can
quickly become sin
but i don't believe that the mere
temptation because christ was tempted
all the way to the cross but he didn't
identify as a sinner a person lives in
this position in the renounce column of
of constant surrender
and
that's it bottom line
okay and so i'm like
yeah
so well that's that isn't that all there
is so you were you were surrendered
yes but i found that i wanted something
more but i couldn't figure out
what what it was that i was after would
you say that you were ever in the rebel
column
uh
no well
i know i did not no i well no
you know i i think that's so far back
that i'm thinking
um
i could see people going through stages
of these you know like in different
points of their life
i could see that yeah i had see i had a
christian upbringing
and an education through scripture and i
knew that there was something
about me that i couldn't figure out
but i didn't
it didn't get angry
with god i just said
i've done
the best i know how
and
i don't know why i am this way
but i knew that that that
my
beliefs and
experiences with christ
were
separate from the other side of me that
felt
uh the sensuality and those kinds of
things i think that it's built in to
know
for us to know that when we're
displeasing god there is a
sense of guilt and
the guilt is actually what helps to
guide us and to wake us up to help us to
come back to christ i couldn't figure
out what that looked like and i think
that many today have turned around and
said well let's just re reshape
scripture
and in my life for 40 years outside of
of the church
i there was no church that could capture
me from what i was raised with from the
from the bible that i grew up with i was
like nope that doesn't make sense that
doesn't agree with scripture i know what
scripture says i don't know what the
answer is but i know it isn't this so i
would not adopt another position
and so i didn't get angry at god and say
uh
or i didn't say hey well this is just
the way it is and i'm a gay christian i
knew that being
gay and that being christian were
directly opposite of one another okay
and so i didn't no i didn't i didn't lay
never a rebel for that but a resistor
yeah very pretty much pretty much and
then you came to the point where
you decided i'm not going to resist
anymore i'm going to renounce yeah and
then
how long would you say you were there
you know how long would you say you were
in each section like how long were you
in the resist and how long were you in
the renowns
um
ballpark well probably
you know in the resist position for me
i didn't uh take it
i wasn't focused on christianity when i
was living in in lgbt culture i believed
yeah i believed that i believe there was
god and i believe that his word was
truth
and and so i didn't give it much more
focus than that
and so
the so that's where i was for 40 years
then 12 years ago
i sat and in front of god one day and i
said
all right i know how scripture reads
from the beginning to end and i know
that that same-sex intimacy is not
something that you condone
and i know that i've lost
uh
40 close friends and over 100
acquaintances to aids
um that played out as consequences for
living in
our lives in ways that didn't honor and
please god
and which be again another long
discussion but as i was looking at that
i said
um
i finally asked the question god what do
you want from me so i had long prayed
for
um
you know god please make me straight i
thought that's what the answer that's
what the solution was
when god isn't so much after that
initially from somebody as he he's after
their heart
and he if we allow a heart change to
take place
he can bring us to different levels of
healing for some you may end up living
celibate until jesus comes for others it
may be that you do meet that one person
of the opposite sex that you fall in
love with that's a miracle from god you
know it's not the same miracle for every
single person
but
even if
i don't marry god is still asking me to
live in agreement with him and to
surrender and submit my flesh to him so
it sounds like even when you got to this
renounce stage
you were still praying for god to work
in a
a different way than you expected if
you're praying you know god please make
me straight
it's like it's almost like your focus
was yeah i was praying that as a kid but
i didn't i didn't pray that in the
renouncement you didn't pray that number
nine no okay
in fact when i came back into the church
i was uh i was very much in the position
of defending
the lgbt community from the standpoint
that
on my ministry today and my conversion
today is not set out to make you
heterosexual i want you to know
that don't let that keep you away from
christ because that's not the overall
goal of christ to make you heterosexual
but as we'll talk about shortly in the
next column there there are some things
to be said about that but in this
position in this renounced position
i found yes i had to surrender myself
every day to christ my my temptations my
desires and also in this renounced
position as a as a converted christian
i found that i even experienced failure
because
i didn't become perfect on earth but we
can become overcomers through christ
and the and the more we get to come to
know christ and the more important that
he is to us the less
dominance our flesh has on us and so i
believe that we can come to a point a
full victory in this particular area
because when you're done you know
probably very well that when you're when
god finishes something great in your
life he's not done with you yet because
he moves on to another maybe it's about
finance maybe it's about eating who
knows there's always something else but
this has been the thorn in my fret my
flesh
and so
um
it's almost like you had
gone from
one point of lacking hope to a new level
of lacking hope if that makes sense yeah
i was like
can there be escape i i need something
more than what i have even though i've
given my life to christ there's there's
got to be more fulfillment than this
and then as these these positions were
being discussed and the then the person
who was outlining the the four positions
entered introduced to me
um
did we get to oh yeah so we did we went
through these here i don't know if
there's any point here that you want to
discuss more
or go over before we move to the next
column you got to the point where you
were emphasizing godly living but god
and god will sustain you yeah
but
it's but i wanted more fullness he
wanted more and so the in which
and so i was like yeah when he was
talking to me like the renounce column i
like yeah that's me that's me and that's
where i've been for 12 years and then it
was like then he said i want to
introduce you to the fourth position
which is the the rebuild position and it
was like i'm all here it's like what do
you mean
and so he said um
if you have developmentally
fallen from grace into the position
where you have uh lived
in
you know opposition to christ or in with
elements of sin in your life
don't you believe that in full surrender
and giving your life over to christ
that
he can developmentally bring you into a
level of healing and of sexual integrity
that he desire desired and meant for you
from the beginning
and i was like
wow that makes complete sense because
he's god
i mean why
why would i
i wouldn't come to christ with a caveat
like well you can do everything you want
with me except i'm not going to let you
do this right and so i share with people
no i didn't go under the water gay and
come up straight when i was baptized and
you know a lot of people will laugh
about that
but
god's intention again for me was not to
start chasing women all over the place
although it's not beyond the capacity of
god to say to introduce me to
that one woman that i would fall in love
with not the entire female population
and yet i had had enough sex in my life
and i'm not saying that i don't want
more but i'm saying
i got that wasn't a primary objective of
god i'm sure to provide me with a sexual
experience it was to develop
my understanding of god that i needed
him more than anything else in my life
and that i needed to bring my desires
and my temptations to him
and walk with him
and and not only that
but to perhaps explore further
with
the design of of psychology and
scripture together only from somebody
who's in totally agreement with
scripture
to see that i could attain
more than what i have currently today
that part of the rebuilding is
in looking at the traumatic events that
have happened in our past or
something maybe non-bonding to a parent
or if you grew up with only one parent
and there's many elements of of damage
or curiosity or circumstantial things
that have brought most people who
identify as lgbt if we really want to go
through the analysis of it
to
discover
the brokenness and that there's elements
of rebuilding
that can help you have a more complete
successful and joyful life in christ and
i said when i heard this i was like
where have you been this is what i want
i want to walk under the guidance of the
holy spirit and with somebody who can
help me walk along the way to help me
achieve new goals in christ not to be
stagnant where i was in the renounced
position but to experience the wholeness
that comes in the rebuild position
there's a lot of people i think that
find themselves in the same position in
different issues
somewhat related for example if you have
been
sexually abused as a child
you know that that creates some
brokenness oh absolutely in the mind
and as a person gets older they they
find that they're dealing with some
issues or they behave a certain way or
their approach to life is is
uh maybe built on top of that
and at some point they
you know in a healthy
if
at some point people
i guess
can come to this in a healthy way and
say you know i need healing i need to be
work through that circumstance and
and be
fulfilled and not
if you can use the word identify
as a
broken abused human being that i can
actually
find life and fulfillment beyond that
yes and so there's all kinds of things
that people have experienced either
younger at some point in their life that
essentially creates
some trauma
that they have to work through to be
healthy again
and what i like about
jesus is when he came
he came to make us whole
and when you when you read the bible and
you study the the biblical languages
you'll find that the word for healing is
is very holistic it's not just
to
you know heal your broken toe or
whatever it's it's the whole person mind
body spirit
all of it it was is to make you
completely new whole again
with
with the bible when you look at it in
the beginning everything was
perfect right
sin came into the world
everything was not perfect after that
and and basically you can look at
approximately the first three chapters
in the last three chapters
and and see what the difference is in
between yeah and god has been
continually working and if you read the
book from beginning to end you'll see
it's like look this is the way i started
it this is the way i designed it and
here's where we're going to end up right
and if you realize that then you then
you know that everything in between is
is brokenness and god trying to restore
that brokenness to wholeness again
and that's in so many aspects of our
lives uh for example um
you know if you look at man's diet in
the beginning you know it was a certain
way
well
in the end it's back to that god is
trying to get people back to that
if you look at for example this the the
sabbath you know adam and eve
uh rested the seventh day right well in
the end that's what god does again and
so i take this approach to life and it's
like and i say to people if god designed
it this way in the beginning and god is
restoring it that way to the end doesn't
it make sense that in the meantime
we cooperate yeah and and try to aim for
that restoration and that pattern
um and live the way that he's trying to
lead us
back to restoration on on so many
different aspects of our life yeah it's
combating with what comes natural with
us it's always it's always something
that we we're to have as a struggle
i think if we look at the details of
this um rebuild position
we see the importance of again
scripture
and acknowledging you know the sin
issue but striving
working towards
the goals that god would have for us of
wholeness that you were bringing out
earlier here
and
to
to associate with with uh discipleship
programs um
being active in the church so when i see
a gay person
who has come back to christ
coming into the church i'm not looking
to put them in a segregated position of
like the pink section over here in the
church but this should be woven into the
church body to
you know okay so maybe life is going to
be
celibacy for this individual so they
need to have fellowship with one another
to get involved in church activities
to to be involved in bible study groups
and
community groups in keeping
a seeing yourself as an integral part of
of the family of god um because you know
there's all kinds of people with all
kinds of issues in the church today this
is just but one you know there's widows
and widowers and
um single people that that have never
married we all have something in our
lives and i believe that
the bible tells us that that god knew us
before we were born that he intends only
good for us no harm and he
he has a purpose for us and so coming
into the church body and going back to
the word which is our our blueprint
blueprint or our love letter from god
begins to show us how we can flourish
in an identity in christ
as opposed to
um
what the world is offering us which is
really a draw on the flesh to live
according to sensuality and what the the
body desires rather than what the mind
could be drawn to if we would put our
focus or allow the focus to be on christ
yeah
you know
thinking about the body
i like the way that paul talks about the
body is
all parts being necessary you know it
it's
it's not just i'm the most important
part or you're the most important part
there all parts have their function all
parts are needed and and we're all a
part of the body of christ and that's
how god sees it he's the head and then
the rest of us work together you know
being directed by him on on how this
thing is to work but but if somebody's
missing from the body
it's not functioning right right you
know and so we need everybody
that's a very you might say inclusive
picture of
god that's the way god is inclusive of
everybody he's like hey you're part of
the body i need you my my church isn't
complete without you that's right so
um i like i like that picture
so i you know i just want to make a
comment too if you're interested in
discussions like this
um that i have a ministry and obviously
in a public speaker and so i offer
seminars and it doesn't matter what the
denomination is because what i have
found in ministry over the past 12 years
is that this is not a um a doctrinal
issue
uh but it is a faith issue and there's
not a denominational issue right it's a
doctor he
yeah but it is a faith issue uh as it
relates to the bible as a whole and that
there are those there are actually
thousands and thousands of people that
are leaving lgbt culture today which is
fascinating to me because they didn't
find the pot of gold at the end of the
rainbow um they they really are seeking
for something more that that wasn't
there that christ can offer to them and
it's just amazing to be part of
organizations today
that are involved with all these
different people with all these
different testimonies that cover all the
letters of the lgbt plus identity so how
do people get ahold of you if they want
you to come and speak or so you can go
to my website which is know his love
that's k-n-o-w like get to know someone
know hislove.org
or you can write to me at uh to know his
love
at uh with the number two at gmail.com
okay
and
i do have one question for you one last
question
what thoughts would you have for anyone
considering their relationship with god
today
i would say
that
what consumes us is so much inwardness
so much focus on self
and
so if you're if you're contemplating
christ
i would say
to
to grab his word
get a translation that that you know
reads well i mean for me the new king
james version works well but sometimes i
go to another version for a little more
clearness of in the way that we talk
today and
you know there's a lot to be said about
the old testament which i think is it's
it's crucial to our our experience in
christ but
for somebody who's just coming to christ
i think that it is important to start in
matthew and you you get the different
perspectives of the four
apostles and
and um and you begin to see the
wonderful things the acts that jesus
does
towards humanity and the hope that he
offers all of us
john you know there's just so many great
things
and
that
invite the holy spirit before you open
up the bible
to
to come and to be with you and to lead
and guide you and you know the lord is
not going to disappoint you
amen amen
well we want to thank you guys for
joining us in this conversation i hope
that you have learned a lot i hope that
these explanations have been beneficial
to you i hope that you will be able to
share them with somebody who needs to to
hear this i think that in some ways you
can apply these to
different experiences that people go
through not just exactly yeah it's an
inclusive message not an exclusive so
many uh issues that people are dealing
with and so we're excited that you've
joined us for another episode of led
live
and we will see you next time thanks for
joining us
[Music]
there has been very few movies in the
history of the world that have
completely changed our world and in 1999
a movie titled the matrix hit the world
stage these stories are often told and
seen over and over again
is it simply just to make money
or is there something more nefarious
behind it
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
you